hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt dieses jahr ist ein bisschen ein
besonderes jahr und ich erinnere mich
noch ganz gut an den anfang des jahres
wir hatten unsere flipchart haben uns
alle hingesetzt haben die ganzen
projekte und messen für diese saat
durchgesprochen und ich dachte mir noch
anfang des jahres
mein gott wie will ich diese ganzen
messen schaffen dennoch freue ich mich
jedes jahr wirklich immer auf den
september auf die erste septemberwoche
aufs erste septemberwochenende sind darf
findet immer die ifa in berlin statt
also die größte internationale
technikmesse und da bin ich ja schon
seit über vier jahren mit bosch
gemeinsam und stelle euch dort die
neuesten technischen highlights vor und
die messe ist für mich wirklich so ein
absolutes muss und ich weiß noch ganz
genau als meine freundin heiraten wollte
und sie wollte ihre hochzeit auf das
wochenende legen habe ich schon zwei
gläser nein geht nicht ich kann nicht so
der nacht kaum denn ich gehe sofort auf
die ifa und dann hat sie hochzeit sogar
noch umgelegt das weiß ich noch
und dieses jahr also ich jetzt echt nie
erwartet wahrscheinlich keiner von uns
und als dann die korona pandemie
ausgebrochen ist war natürlich ganz
schnell klar dass die ifa nicht
stattfindet und es war für mich
tatsächlich muss ich echt sagen ich war
schon sehr enttäuscht klar du kannst
nicht auf eine messe gehen wenn gehabt
total die pandemie ist und es war
einfach so war unser berlin wochenende
findet nicht statt wir gehen nicht auf
die messe und für mich war es einfach
die letzten jahre immer richtig toll
weil ich dort in der küche mich austoben
konnte ich habe gekocht und gebacken und
hunderte und tausende von euch waren zu
gast da wir haben uns unterhalten und
kennengelernt autogrammstunden gemacht
es ging natürlich auch um die highlights
um den neuen innovationen und ich hab da
wirklich immer super intensive tage
verbracht und ja das war halt dieses
jahr schon sowieso wie so ein luftballon
der einfach zerplatzt und wir haben es
echt gefragt nur toll was machen wir
dieses jahr
und natürlich hat bosch dieses jahr auch
wieder ganz ganz viele highlights und
viele innovationen entwickelt und die
wollten wir auch vorstellen und wir
haben uns wirklich gemeinsam mit bosch
hingesetzt und haben überlegt ja was
machen wir denn jetzt
und für mich war es dann echt allein
schon dass er mich gefragt haben also
sollte es für mich nicht einfach so eine
firma die da so existiert das sind
wirklich langjährige partner aber noch
viel mehr
langjährige freunde und eins muss ich
noch sagen mit bosch arbeite ich schon
wirklich seit über vier jahren zusammen
und es ist nicht einfach eine
partnerschaft sondern es ist wirklich
eine freundschaft entstanden und ich
habe mich damals auch für bosch
entschieden weil ich die menschen die
dort arbeiten einfach so sehr geschätzt
habe und zwar einfach sofort so der
sympathiefaktor ist übergesprungen also
wenn ich als an harald denkt am kinos an
toni an florence an den michael dann
muss ich halt echt sagen dass mir da
auch schon die freundschaft wichtiger
ist sogar als die partnerschaft und es
hat einfach von anfang an super gepasst
und gerade wenn sie an die bosch geräte
denke die sind so bodenständig man hat
wirklich was von wenig technik wirst du
viel technik jemand wie meine mutter zum
beispiel tieren santoro nicht so viel
technik nimmt sich dann ein bisschen was
einfachere ist jemand der sagt ich
möchte mir den arbeitsalltag erleichtern
da kann natürlich auch zu künstlicher
intelligenz zurückgreifen und sich
wirklich beim kochen und backen leiten
lassen
aber wie gesagt das ist einfach eine
freundschaft die jetzt auch über die
jahre entstanden ist und für mich war es
echt ein krasser ritterschlag dass ich
jetzt diese iv messe einfach bei mir zu
hause habe stattfinden lassen dürfen
also vielleicht an der stelle nochmal
vielen vielen dank an euch kinos und ton
und harald danke für euer vertrauen und
danke dass ich das ganze bei mir zu
hause machen durfte wie ihr euch
vielleicht vorstellen könnte das ganze
wurde jetzt nicht lange im voraus
geplant denn die pandemie hat uns alle
plötzlich getroffen plötzlich kam der
lockdown plötzlich war überall alles
geschlossen und wir haben jetzt überlegt
okay wie machen wir wo und vor allem
wann
und es war wirklich so eine krasse
kurzschlussreaktion
sie haben mir die ganzen neuen geräte
gezeigt wir haben innerhalb von zwei
wochen wurden die drehbücher geschrieben
denn ihr müsst euch vorstellen wenn ich
auf der messe bin dann habe ich da die
annette neben mir von bosch die erklärt
mir dann alles was neu ist was die neuen
features sind die neuen funktionen sind
und dann erklärt sie mir dass ich stehe
dann vor dem gerät und erklärt euch in
die kamera jetzt natürlich musste alles
gut vorbereitet werden und wir haben uns
dann auch dazu bereit erklärt unser
komplettes haus sozusagen frei zu geben
und zu sagen okay baut einfach alles ein
wo ihr wollt und wie ihr wollt
ich habe das ganze ein bisschen
unterschätzt muss ich sagen weil wir
saßen dann sonntags noch auf der
terrasse und ich wusste okay das
drehteam rückte an und dann kamen
plötzlich lkws
und menschen und haben einfach so
komplett das ganze haus irgendwie
umgebaut
aber dazu später noch ja und wir wollten
das ganze muss ich auch sagen am anfang
selber drehen also josch und vivi und
und der frank und marcel und alle aber
das ganze war einfach am zeitlich nicht
möglich weil wir wirklich zeitlich auch
sehr eingespannt waren und wir hatten
wir persönlich oder ich persönlich
einfach nur diese eine woche zeit die
ganzen videos zu drehen und deswegen
haben das zeitlich nicht hingekriegt
also hatten wir ein richtig cooles
produktionsteam an der seite und die
haben sich dann auch zusammengesetzt mit
tsm florence und amboss und haben dann
gesagt okay wir schreiben jetzt die
drehbücher wir haben statt 14 geräte
insgesamt oder sogar mehr
aber wir haben 14 videos im am ende
gemacht und wir haben dann drehbücher
geschrieben weil da war es wirklich so
wir mussten praktisch von sequenz zu
sequenz ist wird immer so ein teil des
hauses beleuchtet und da ist es dann
nicht so dass man dann eine lampe
hinstellt sondern es war wirklich ein
komplettes set up wie bei einem
werbedreh eben auch und sowas muss man
natürlich gut vorbereiten also wurden
drehbücher geschrieben was ich alles
sagen möchte was sich alles vorstellen
möchte und für mich war die
schwierigkeit darin dass ich praktisch
nicht einen film von anfang bis ende
fertig drehen konnte sozusagen über ein
geschirrspüler zum beispiel weil sowas
kann ich muss ich schon sagen aus dem
stegreif also ich kann mich noch
hinstellen und über die
geschirrspülmaschine erzählen was sie an
neuheiten hart funktionen reinigung
bedienung aber wenn du natürlich 24
geräte im kopf haben musst und dann
immer wieder verschiedene setups hass
und verschiedene drehorte muss das
natürlich alles niedergeschrieben werden
und so haben wir das gemacht und so
wurde einmal unser komplettes haus
belagert und wer angefangen die videos
zu drehen und das war alles
naja kraft murat hat das ganze backstage
ein bisschen begleitet und ich glaube
murat hat euch auch ein bisschen was
dazu zu erzählen
ziemlich
ja es ist ein unglaublich großes team
was ist also in der größenordnung haben
wir noch nie gefilmt wir haben schon mal
in der größenordnung gedreht für vox war
das mal wo wir die rallye serie gemacht
haben und jetzt haben sie unseren
komplett unsere komplette garage in
beschlag genommen was ist wir haben eine
garage aus alles voll gestellt mit
produkten wie eingebaut werden oder
selbst wenn sie gewechselt werden es ist
wirklich der wahnsinn und es wird zehn
tage lang so sein das heißt zehn tage
lang wird unser haus komplett in
beschlag genommen für diesen trip für
diesen virtuellen rundgang von der ifa
und die heißen waghäusel angekommen also
man jetzt schon immer gesagt sally
eigentlich müsstest du nach berlin da
ist alles da kannst du noch größer
werden wir uns dann eben bleiben hier
und jetzt ist berlin ist eva und jetzt
ist er hier in waghäusel und er richtig
gigantische geschichte jetzt kriegen wir
schon ein hubschrauber die suche
wahrscheinlichen juni und das ist das
ganze set so und die milch juni
juni
nein ich war lange zeit waren wir für
die radstation bergtour zu meditieren
momentan macht das wetter mit und hier
sitzt das ganze team ist nachher wir
haben caterer und zwar es cool ist auch
noch ihr wisst ja dank corona geht es
den ganzen caterer und den ganzen
restaurants ja nicht so gut und da ist
so viel menschen da sind haben die leute
auch was von unserer region davon
und das ist es kristall hotel kristall
in kirrlach deshalb sehr beliefert mit
mit essen mit getränk mit allem drum und
dran
und hier hinten sehen wir schon ein
bisschen ein lkw mit der ware drin
hier gratis vorne sei jedoch ein lkw mit
ware drin das ist echt wahnsinn richtige
materialschlacht was hier gemacht wird
es ist wie ein riesiger kinofilm dreh
bei uns in waghäusel und jetzt geben wir
nicht wie andere räume dass sie mir das
glaubt was ja alles gerade passiert
gehen wir jetzt mal kurz rein und da ist
michael ikrath am drehen und es geht
gerade um den backofen ich glaube es
geht um die serie 8 die carbon black
edition die wir selber haben
da gibt es ein paar coole neuheiten
künstliche intelligenz also wirklich
künstliche intelligenz bis etwas ganz
cooles künstliche intelligenz ist der
backofen lernt mit das heißt jetzt
völlig clean probleme haben in der buck
oft schon schlauer ist als er hat der
grünen natürlich ein problem ist leider
so und des videos zu dem backofen mit
künstliche intelligenz der cdu jetzt was
die seele gedreht hat so sitzt nämlich
aus
die neuen backofen mit k also
künstlicher intelligenz erleichtern den
alltag enorm
sie lernen durch eine stetig wachsende
anzahl an informationen aus zahlreichen
back und brand vorging der home connect
community ständig dazu je öfter und
intensiver ein backofen genutzt wird
desto genauer kann er vorhersagen wann
der kuchen oder braten dieser lkw hier
zb ist voll mit licht equipment liest
ist saumäßig wichtig beim dreh und wie
gesagt eine ganze lkw ist voll mit licht
samt folien und ständern und was weiß
ich was eine unglaubliche summe ich bin
mir ganz ganz sicher was meinst du was
ist eine ganze lkw inhalt kostet eine
halbe million bereichen also mehr
ungefähr mehr als eine halbe million ist
wahnsinn mit lichttechnik
meist ist es so dass ich solche
unternehmen ist nicht selber kaufen
sondern immer filmverleihe das im
ausland gibt es fast in jeder größeren
stadt so riesengroße filmverleih und wie
gesagt alles eingepackt und allem drum
und dran eine ganz andere geschichte so
bei uns daheim gibt es eine goldene
regel egal ob der präsident kommt oder
die königin oder der kaiser wie auch
immer bei uns heißt die goldene regel zu
hause immer schule aussehen
daran muss sich jeder halten ich muss
auch über wiederum sagen leute zieht
eure schuhe aus bei mir daheim läuft
keiner rum ohne schuhe oder diese
slippies und sie das lieblingslied man
sich einfach über die über die schule
drüber zack so mann hinter schmutz nicht
mit nach hause ob ich das selber dran
machen warum ich keine socken rumlaufen
ich bin mit ohne ohne schuhe sich
ziemlich klein aus und deswegen sich
jetzt an vor der kamera sondern auch
wieder verwenden jetzt gebe rein
so im real life ist es normalerweise der
raum von der sarah von unserem
fotografien und jetzt ist die anderen da
und diana die ist auch von von der
filmcrew und sie ist kameratechnik
richtig an genau und was sie jetzt
gerade macht und zwar sie tut gerne
daten regeln nennt sich dass das heißt
die schweine die ganzen daten auf karten
auf 6 und dran und man sieht hier schon
ein bisschen ganzen videos das ist
gerade ist wieder wo die zelle dem
backofen mit der künstlichen intelligenz
erklärt richtig genau künstliche
intelligenz das ist wenn der backofen
schlauer ist als der ehemann richtig
sind genau absolut richtig auch hier war
eine coole geschichte und die speichen
die ganzen daten darf nichts verloren
geht schon mal vorher im ganzen drehtag
gemacht und drehtag ist richtig richtig
asche richtig habe ich recht plötzlich
die daten weg dann haben wir ein
riesenproblem ist es hier schon mal
passiert sei noch nie passiert weil du
eine schlaue erna wisst genau ist ein
schlauer ist noch nie passiert und es
ist schon mal passiert muss ich sagen
wir mal mit zwei drehtage gehabt und
dann waren die karten einfach kaputt
dass das kann passieren deswegen machen
wir auch immer recht 68 mal von ihrer
künstler hatte noch mal ein paar kopien
okay hier in diesem raum normalerweise
zu dieser fotos bearbeiten und deshalb
diana drin und tut dann sieben tage
jetzt daten regelt genau
danke jetzt gehen wir weiter und zwar
jetzt gehen wir eigentlich das richtige
foto studio von uns wo eigentlich die
saar an unsere fotografen die ganzen
fotos machen und wie es da drin aussieht
das glaubte mir nicht weil ich habe ihn
vorher um nachher bild und ich zeige ich
wollte es nachher wird so das ist
normalerweise der raum wo wir eigentlich
fotos schießen auf unserem holzbrett und
der ist auch wieder vorgestellt voll mit
technik und nun mal ein bisschen dass er
ein bisschen auf meine technik versteht
und wie viel geld ist ja eigentlich geht
wie gesagt ist geliehen es ist auch
nicht von mir geliehen und zwar allein
diese objektive hier also dieser tisch
locker mal um die 200 granaten
mindestens mindestens dann was wir auch
haben ist eine alexa mini und zwar
gerade die mit dem promoter dies war
fünf jahre alt hier bist du auch schon
normal
locker dabei mit 100000 also das ding
ist wirklich hier in diesem raum steht
locker als ungelogen mal mit dreiviertel
millionen bis millionen nur ein
equipment ja dann wenn die zentrische
steht schon mal eine million mehr drin
ja dann ist die sally menschen zwei
millionen wert mindestens ich bin
unbezahlbar nicht mal mit der mastercard
kann man mich bezahlen also eine richtig
krasse geschichte eine materialschlacht
der technik schlacht aber das seht ihr
mal wie die wie cool oder wie wichtig
und viel arbeit zum ganz kleiner
werbespot eigentlich ist und ja gerade
beim werbespot gebe dank zum nächsten
werbespot und zwar geht es hier um die
entlüftungsanlage oder belüftungsanlage
die scheibe so hochfährt und
abzugshauben und zwar gibt es da was
ganz ganz groß ist ja der kochkunst wird
abgezogen mit einer krassen scheibe
momentan ist der neueste hit von bosch
gibt es jetzt demnächst beim handel und
dies hätten dieses video gedreht was da
für eine coole kamera technik dahinter
steckt und wie q dieser spot nicht
geworden ist das seht ihr mal jetzt
mein absolutes highlight unter den
aktuellen bosch neuheiten ist dieser
dunstabzug das ist wie kein anderer
perfekt in meiner küche einfügt so jetzt
immer bei uns in der küche oder was ist
mal vorher war und ihr seht das ist eine
richtig krasse geschichte wird die
technik dahinter steht kommen kurz mit
der roman ist gerade dabei und zwar
filmte den backofen und rhade und hier
ist ein richtiges labyrinth aufgebaut
und guck mal hier war geht es weiter
also ihr seht es ist ein ganz anderes
filmen also das ist sieht nicht aus wie
meine küche zu hause und jetzt müssen
auch ein bisschen still sein und still
sein ist eigentlich das nächste
schlagwort weil da gibt's auch was
richtig cool ist hat uns allen video
gerade eben gemacht und zwar geht es um
eine spülmaschine die so leise ist dass
man eigentlich eine stecknadel fallen
hören
und dieses video dazu das schaut euch
mal jetzt an jungs wenig hilfe braucht
ihr wisst bescheid
ich habe den größten dönerladen in
karlsruhe die lachen alle man sieht
nicht weniger machen aber ich höre mehr
leistung weniger verbrauch
das zeichnet die neuen perfect
geschirrspüler aus die neue
geschäftsstelle reihe hat es wirklich in
sich
mit einer topausstattung unglaublich
sparsam 100% vernetzt leise und auf
knopfdruck noch leiser dass das war mal
früher der raum wo wir gegessen haben im
ganzen team zusammen alles komplett
abgedunkelt alles dunkel gemacht hier
wird wirklich die das licht ist so
extrem wichtig bei einem dreh ich glaube
allein nur das licht ganzen tag
aufgestellt in den ganzen tag nicht
aufgestellt draußen ein sonnensegel
gemacht bei uns im garten da gehen jetzt
auch mal kurz hin
es ist wichtig ist ein licht ist einer
der wichtigsten dinge beim video drehen
ich geh mal kurz raus ich zeige schon
mal ganz gut
das sind drei von der tankstelle und
zwar die sind für die technik zuständig
jungs das heißt die bauen die ganzen
küchen zusammen auseinander und allem
drum und dran oder stimmt es dass orte
weiger hier kommt man tatsächlich zeigt
so sieht momentan unser kräutergarten
aus und da war mal die terrasse und da
ist alles abgedunkelt das einfach
einfach lichteinfall sei es also möglich
einen ganzen tag nur fürs nicht ja zur
jüngsten immer was essen gleich noch hab
ja auch immer also wenn ich was sms
tierisch die spülmaschine tauschen die
da drin in unser ding okay also wie
gesagt nach jedem trainer etwas
getauscht und jetzt gleich die
spülmaschine
und dessen wirklich ganz ganz immer ganz
ganz schnell wechseln das heißt
maschinerie maschine raus ein neues
gerät ein neues gerät raus muss ein
fliegender wechsel sei es gibt ja mit
dem zeit weil es ist nicht so dass jeder
drehtag unglaublich viel geld kostet
unglaublich viel arbeit ist und deswegen
müsse man so schnell fertig werden wie
es nur geht und wir machen das schon
jungs geilich es sinn macht es einfach
so wie es euch schon mal gezeigt habe
die rohre nicht vertauschen und dann
läuft es hört keiner auf mich genau ruft
dann um luft genau das ist richtig so
und wie gesagt unsere kirche komplett
umgestellt so sitzt ja auch aus also
richtig dunkel können wir noch sehen wir
es ist noch hell genug ist gerade noch
so ok
was ich aber ganz cool finde ist home
connect fähige backöfen das bringt
wirklich was weil ihr wisst ja zum
beispiel das slf gibt und zwar gibt sie
sally obwohl sie ihre ganzen rezepte
drauf hast du kannst du im backofen
schicken und der backofen stellt
automatisch die heiz art ein also für
die heißluft umluft wo er unter
oberhitze umluft wie auch immer stellt
automatisch ein und auch die zeit das
heißt nichts mehr machen als einfach mit
dem handy das einem backofen schicken
dann hat es doch richtig coole es ist
funktionen das heißt du hast ein schönes
rinderfilet wenn du jetzt nicht veganer
bist tust das rinderfilet in den
backofen machst du es ist funktion und
sagst einfach hinter viele 800 gramm zum
beispiel je nachdem wie kilogramm hast
und dann kommt dass viele wirklich
perfekt raus du musst nicht mehr
nachschauen dessen die sensoren die im
backofen und drinnen sind ganz
gigantische rallye serie 8 home connect
wenige geräte wird durch die decke gehen
weil sie einfach sinnhaft ich sind und
das video hat meine frau gestern schon
gedreht sie kann es besser erklären als
ich an sonst ein echtes gesicht von
bosch leider will nicht das gericht von
bosch dass meine frau und die erklärt
euch das in dem folgenden werbespot geht
es funktioniert
mit home connect kann ich meine
kreativität in der küche voll und ganz
ausleben
ich kann einfach in der großen
rezeptsammlung stöbern und die
unterschiedlichsten gerichte
ausprobieren die einstellungen aus dem
rezept schicke ich dann direkt aus der
home connect app an meinen backofen
ich meine wie soll ich meinem garten
winter holen wenn ich nicht in meinen
garten kommen doch ich mache etwas wenn
was passiert was ein arbeitsumfeld okay
aber kein fahrlässiges war vollkommen
gerechtfertigt ok
b
und
so sei
so und zwar bis jetzt ein neuer
kühlschrank der hat wahnsinnige sachen
das soll ich mal in hau erklären und was
halt auch coole das natürlich schwarz
klar aber das jetzt nicht neue high
school ist hat einen fingerprint
oberfläche das heißt es kann natürlich
alles war mit die kinder hast
drübergehen keine gibt keine flecken mit
den neuen geräumigen und komfortablen
seite sei kühl und gefrierkombinationen
bietet bausteine große auswahl in
unterschiedlichen preisklassen an mein
favorit bei den neuzugängen ist dieses
schätzchen hier sowohl die front als
auch die seitenwände sind in stylischem
schwarz gestaltet hier
du bist auch 0 aufgeregt ich will und
die macht wirklich hier haut mal kurz 22
erklärvideos raus aus den ganzen
begriffen was es alles gibt
scheibenwischer waschmaschinen und was
weis ich mir schnell aufgeregt und ich
sehe gerade du hast ein bisschen gemüse
zwischen den zehen
oh mein gott ich muss in die maske dann
mal gucken also immer noch echt jetzt
noch mit kein mensch ja voll mit 20 hat
sich keiner was sagen oh mein gott drei
tage drehen und sonst welche gemüse
zwischen 10 hat keiner gesagt kommt
alles vor natürlichste gemüse zu sehen
das ist ein ganzer baum ich was
inzwischen zehn hast ja jetzt gehen mal
an einen geheimen ort und zwar das was
aussieht wie ein wc ist auch einen ec
und zwar ist hier die basken für den
ganzen see und die masse gemacht
julia so und wir lassen unsere freundin
und zwar schon seit zwei jahren seit
zwei jahren wohnt sie hier
in dem raum hier wir klopfen jemand
macht die tür auch rational und immer
guten morgen
die julia die war schon bei uns als wir
die die serie mit box gemacht haben und
zwar war das backen kochen war es singen
was genau und einfach sally und hier
wird dann ich zähle geschminkt
normalerweise mache ich das immer aber
heute geht's los und ja es ist auch
interessant vielleicht für andere
zuschauer in ihre kinder diese beauty
tutorials was du stehst da gerade drauf
wie nennt sich das als make up artist
not so macht mut drauf nennt sich das
new der also luft luft teuer verpackt
darf ich mich gerade kurz vor schluss
bin ich kurz übergeben aber auf jeden
fall also ganz cool
und jetzt wird sie geschminkt auf dem
klo
wenn man natürlich nicht die
räumlichkeiten ja und ja er ist der ton
genau mit klopapier und großem ton
und was machst du jetzt wir werden hier
die augenränder weg gemacht oder oder
aber ich finde ich bin immer um so älter
sie wird umso schöner wird sie da das
ist man das normalerweise männer spruch
ja das geht gar nicht so wusstet ihr
dass der mensch ab 25 stirbt der mensch
eigentlich bis zu 25 also ab 24 wächst
alles bei mensch und dann beginnt der
innenverwaltung beginnt ja schon das
sterben wir alles schon mit der geburt
auch lustig ja das ist das sterben
beginnt mit der geburt mit 24 wird aber
alles aufzuwachsen ist auf die hände auf
die füße die nase und die ohren
ja bei mir wächst dann aber mir ist aber
auch weiter gewachsen ich weiß ich was
falsch gelaufen ist ja auf jeden fall
jetzt geht es weiter
machst du noch so kulturring noch und
macht macht man sowas so konnte
okay du hast mir da noch gemacht wird
dann als komplizin gemacht nennt sich
das bleaching sie ist und werden die
augenbrauen noch gezupft oder bleibt ist
so weiß ich nicht nein ich sehr schön
aus alles passen was machst du hast
gesagt auch so auf jeden fall und
bekriegen und wie kriegt man nach in die
farbe alles wieder runter gallseife oder
hinten auf den kopf fallen
okay aber durch kärcher
jawohl wir durch den sc 4 kann ich nur
empfehlen scp dampfreiniger ganz toll
und wie oft muss man das machen ist
interessiert solche jetzt muss man das
so ist so schmücken am tag auch einmal
gegessen
gut ich hab mich sehr schäme ich mich
geschminkt war hochzeit 2008
was haben jetzt 22 zwar habe ich 2008
geheiratet sind ja erst 2008 habe ich
geheiratet
ja wahnsinn ja da haben sie mich
geschminkt 2008 und zwar solche mal die
bilder zeigen komme nicht einmal ganz
kurz ein bild von 2008 und zwar hier
sehe ich aus wie rand der taxifahrer aus
london
ok du siehst gut aus
jetzt kannst du vor der kamera was auch
ganz wichtig ist oftmals weniger das
jetzt so sieht neben der kamera sehr
dass jetzt nicht wenn ich jetzt ein foto
schießen würde würde die jetzt denken
sie ist überschminkt aber die kamera
geschluckt sehr sehr viel habe ich recht
julia du hast erfahren ja erst nicht was
du drauf kommt sodann beleuchtet dass
sie total blass aussieht also wenn es
nicht auf dich drauf kommt dann wird sie
weg gestrahlt haben
ich will keine komische gedanken kann
sagen es war nur ein kleines war nur der
wein gedankenstrich es war einfach ein
visueller gedankenstrich okay ich mache
weiter ich gehe jetzt mal rein und
machen die da drin machen ok können wir
wieder bringen
ja ich höre nicht auf die frauen komm
mit wir müssen zwischen spielen kommen
das ist der wahre kühlschrank von bosch
den kennt ja auch von der messe vom
letzten jahr noch der hat jetzt neue
styles neue farben man kann sich
individualisieren und s klasse ist wir
haben jetzt natürlich hier nur einen
einzigen und jetzt wird eine 3d
animation mittels animiert das heißt du
siehst ganz ganz ganz viele verschiedene
designs ganz verschiedene farben und es
ist ein ganzes team was nachher wirklich
komplett 3d animiert wird
hier steht er da und so sitzt nach einem
video aus und zwar genau so
wer kennt das nicht die richtige farbe
zu finden ist oftmals gar nicht so
einfach gefällt mir die farbe die ich
heute auswähle auch noch morgen die
meisten menschen entscheiden sich daher
oft für eine welt küche aber das muss
gar nicht sein dass die kamera laufen
ausgelassen mit gemüse und polonaise
herz gehört ich mache es sprechen
okay ihr leben heute ist tag und ich
schlaf seit vier nächten nicht mehr weil
meine augen nacht im flattern und ich
befürchte es ist wegen den ganzen
bildschirm und wegen dem ganzen licht
ich weiß nicht was machen wir so anders
und die ganzen texte umhin kommt die
ganzen sechs ja- und nachts da freu mich
ich möchte sie eine schöne träume weil
ich trage so perfekt perfekt aber es
fliegen sie die buchstaben vor meinem
geistigen auge angeflogen so weiß und
schon kommst du ab und zu in der maske
ich liegt manchmal ein vor allem wenn
sie mit ihren nägeln so meine kopfhaut
und dann was ich auch heute sich der
traum aller frauen kann auf eine schwach
und sähen gut aus wenn sie mich dann
geschminkt hat durch den 50
ich würde so gerne mal so eine art immer
strenger werden weißt du von früher wo
ich meine kosten
in meinem leben gibt es nur zwei fragen
die mich beschäftigen was ziehe ich
heute an
ja das ist eigentlich bei uns im
hauswirtschaftsraum und hier wird das
gleiche dreht wie die neuen bosch
waschmaschine funktioniert
die sind richtig tricky und zwar das
kasse ist dass die waschmaschinen
holztag schon intelligenter sind als dre
dass ich auch mal im keller die
geschichte dass irgendwann mal cyborgs
und roboter die menschheit übernehmen
werden weil sich mein schlimm ist hatte
schon die waschmaschinen menschen
übernimmt wie zb dazu sagen dass die
waschmaschine die macht ja alles
selbstständig eigenständig macht die
wäsche alles was er nicht kann und macht
die wäsche nicht kaputt
das ist wenig vorher von der eidos
gehört hätte hätte ich dann teil warten
müssen so ist sein problem
wir werden bald nicht mehr gebraucht
weil die waschmaschine funktioniert
aha ok und wie die funktioniert ist euch
mal nichts erklären okay die neuen
warsteiner von bosch sind wahre
alleskönner waschen trocknen und dampf
in einem gerät betrank fertige wäsche
wasche trockner sind die optimale lösung
in engen räumen
die neuen barsch trockner von bosch sind
praktische helfer für jeden nicht nur
ein platzproblem
so oben erklärt ja sli die eidos
waschmaschine und jetzt haben wir hier
sonst nicht zusammen aufgebaut die
letzten zwei tage
okay der stadt geholfen das besondere an
dieser waschmaschine ist das fast so
groß wie du jetzt reizt vielleicht petit
kohle kommt wenn wir da hochklettern und
dann nimmst drauf sitzen und dann die
moderation machen so okay jetzt können
wir die anmoderation machen so fand das
cool an dieser waschmaschine das ist wie
so ein altes pärchen also eigentlich wir
zwei und diese zwei machen das was wir
zwar nicht machen wir kommen jetzt die
kommunizieren miteinander und verfolgen
das steverforum dieser waschmaschine tue
ich jetzt auf 60 grad baumwolle waschen
okay dann sag' diese waschmaschine sagt
er zum trockener hey ich hab baumwolle
war schon auf 60 grad und die stellt
sich automatisch ein
das heißt die wäsche raus und kann es
einfach nur rein machen und muss nicht
mehr einstellen ist alles automatisch
wahnsinn oder wieder so ein produkt wo
er merk schlauer als der gewinn
kümmert euch nicht so locker auf alle
bosch waschmaschinen draufschreiben
schlauer als der binden das ist eine
coole geschichte so auf jeden fall diese
brutale szene schneiden das nicht raus
und das andere coole ist wenn du jetzt
zb die wahrscheinlich fertig ist okay
dann kriegst du wenn du möchtest eine
push benachrichtigung die wo dann heißt
gummi waschmaschine ist fertig du musst
dich nur herlaufen bis drei machen und
das ding läuft von alleine
wahnsinn das ist doch toll für den
westen zuständig
ja ich sage also das ist wie gesagt das
alte pärchen das ist wenn daheim schon
nicht mehr mit dem ehepartner
kommuniziert wird machen deswegen ist
die waschmaschine
so ist es genau kennst du ja auch genau
wie waschmaschinen reden mehr
miteinander als die kirche geiles ding
wirklich tolles ding und eigentlich
jetzt auch wie das ding wirklich
funktioniert das kann euch mal in diesen
jetzigen video mal erklären
die kann es nicht besser als wir
erklären man irgendwie immer wenn mir
sagt claire kommt irgendwie misstraut
versteht was ich meine wir keine warum
warum du hast doch die waschmaschinen
daheim hat sag mal du hast du schon eine
keine insel sondern dass gerade mal drei
minuten erfahren dass ich genug sein
schaut euch das video an
jetzt habe ich euch ein paar vorstellen
dass so richtig gut zusammen passt die
bosch waschmaschine und der bosch
trockner im inox design die beiden sind
aber nicht nur optisch ein paar
sie verstehen sich auch hervorragend
beide können über home connect verbunden
werden auf jeden fall hier werden
natürlich komplett die wie soll ich
sagen die nicht eingestellt hier werden
wenn wir aufgestellt wegen schalen und
allem drum und dran
und das tolle ist dass wird
digitalisiert macht man heutzutage
übrigens auch wenn jetzt zum beispiel
mal sein so ein auto werbespot sie also
früh rund 20 autos genommen das gleiche
modell reihe und nun verschiedene farben
oder ich militär benzin so lang entlang
gefahren heißt der fanszene nach hat der
kapitän
termin 20 studenten genau nicht herum
so dass nicht rausbringen auf jeden fall
für mich schon ein und zwar das coole
ist man hat ja früher wie gesagt bei
seinem fernseher wird wie autos und man
wollte die verschiedenen farben zeigen
aber mich 20 fahrzeuge in die region
gefahren um diesen werbespot zu drehen
und heutzutage wird alles so
digitalisiert das heißt man nimmt nur
ein auto fährt ist ein und es fällt kein
mehr auf das ist eigentlich gar nicht
echt ist genau das ist ja auch wie bei
dir was ich einführung ja ja ja auf
jeden fall ist fällt keinem auf ist uns
wie beim mini ist auch niemand
aufgefallen das ja eigentlich ganz ganz
beschränkt 150 ja abstand ja also eine
körperlänge von mir sehen wir sind an
einem halb körperlänge ja auf jeden fall
wie gesagt das ganze haus beschlagnahmt
kann es kaum noch zähne putzen gehen
ohne dass sich jemand erwischt coole
geschichte aber auch eine erfahrung für
uns ist aber schon hässlich muss ich
sagen wenn man zehn tage sonntag hat und
es ist wirklich von morgens bis abends
hätten wir von morgens um sieben bis
abends um 21 uhr gedreht das ist der
wahnsinn
dann hat meine frau sowie stress und aus
diesem stress heraus wachsen noch für
alle noch buchten oder macht noch eis
oder macht irgendwie getränke das ganze
team schon der wahnsinn was mache ich
mir sicher dass ich dir nix machen ja es
ist so dass ich dir nichts macht nein
nein nein nein nein das war nicht auf
jeden fall richtig coole videos und
tolle geräte muss man es sagen also ich
finde auch mal schön dass made in
germany so extrem innovativ ist oftmals
gar nicht erzählt aber es ist wahnsinn
nein ich schickte keine gerichtstermine
serie aber eine ganz andere serie ist
genau eine andere serie geht weiter
ich muss jeden tag mit dem mitmachen
das problem war ja früher wirklich
beleidigt mich ja schon seit 13 jahren
und seit 14 jahren leidet er mich und um
hat er sich gedacht er macht es
beruflich und seitdem arbeitet er bei
uns so
jetzt reißt mir langsam ich habe zu
meiner frau mal wie bösen weichen musste
mir bist mach zell zell ii
ich würde einfach ich bin ich vielleicht
gar nicht mehr mit ihr arbeiten sagt
meiner frau dass sie ein anderer
abteilung möchte ich möchte mich nicht
mehr arbeiten melden irgendwie kann ich
gar nicht profis machen ja ja machen
so jetzt bin ich allein in der küche und
kinder oftmals ist problem auf
cerankochfeld kratzer mit töpfen oder
irgendwie jedes ceranfeld ist irgendwann
mal zerkratzt dagegen fix machen aber
jetzt gibt es war es ganz ganz cool ist
und das hat auch mit diesem messer zu
tun das ist ein massaker an japanisches
damals messe aus vg10 gold stahl und
diesem es ist richtig scharf und was den
neuen kochfelder die neuen generation zu
drauf haben das wäre der wahnsinn aber
am besten zeitlich mal dass dies ende
der erste kratzer im auto diesen moment
kennt glaube ich jeder und da ist so
ärgerlich ein kochfeldern entstehen die
meisten kratzer durch sand staub und
aggressive schwämme gas pro tag ist 95%
kratz resistenter gegen sand und staub
und 70 prozent gegen aggressive
schwimmen also ich muss schon sagen vor
der allererste aufnahme war echt krass
aufgeregt weil ich einfach diese masse
an texten vor mir hatte und wir haben
die texte so gemacht die waren schon als
wir hatten sie schon grob vorgeschrieben
flores hat mir jeden tag immer was
zugeschickt und wir haben aber immer
morgens nochmals immer nochmal alles
durchgegangen was wir an dem tag drehen
wollen wir haben nochmal änderungen
gemacht wo könnte man etwas einfacher
oder kürzer erklären weil gerade diese
videos es sind ja schon erklärvideos
geworden also wirklich so in 23 minuten
kurz was ist das wichtigste über dieses
gerät und das musste ich dann eben immer
aufsplitten und habe am tag vielleicht
auch mal über zehn geräte gleichzeitig
gesprochen oder direkt nacheinander in
der gleichen situation und es war für
mich natürlich auch schwierig weil ich
dann nicht in meiner umgangssprache so
sprechen konnte sondern ich musste mir
praktisch den text merken nur teilweise
durfte ich ihn auch ablesen aber das
natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig
weil ich jetzt nicht der typ bin der
text abliest sondern eher so der tipp
der zur aus dem stegreif heraus spricht
und sich sachen kurz merkt und daneben
spricht und deswegen ist es vielleicht
so dass ich nur videos ein bisschen
anders da und kompakter und kürzer
spreche aber ich habe halt immer
versucht alle so direkt auf den punkt zu
bringen und dann muss man überlegen die
eine situation ist montag um 8 uhr
drüben im wohnzimmer entstanden die
nächste situation im gleichen video ist
freitagnachmittag hier in der küche
entstanden die wieder andere situation
war mittwochvormittag dort drüben also
es war halt echt immer alles querbeet
und durcheinander
aber ich muss sagen das team hat es mir
auch ein bisschen leichter gemacht vor
die ersten paar stunden waren echt krass
da war ich echt aufgeregt weil ich
einfach auch nicht wusste sofort
feedback her also es hat aber keiner was
gesagt was jetzt gut oder nicht so gut
und irgendwann waren wir echt mega
eingespielt auch cup im roman und
kameramann da wusste man immer genau was
er sagen muss oder ebenso kurzes
feedback gut oder nicht so und dann
musste ich auch schon okay das passt
oder das mache ich noch mal neu und da
muss ich sagen wann es halt echt krass
sechs intensive tage von morgens bis
abends und ich habe auch echt schlecht
geschlafen teilweise weil ich so dachte
okay morgen geht es um die
geschirrspülmaschine und ich hab dann
schon nachts geträumt von den ganzen
geräten aber ich hatte wirklich so eine
woche lang den kopf nur hier und war
schon sehr gut und ich denke dass die
videos am ende auch so geworden sind
dass ihr euch die videos einfach
anschauen könnt wenn ihr sagt okay ich
interessiere mich jetzt wieder neue
geschirrspülmaschine und dann habt ihr
das video könnt ihr übrigens auf dem
boxclub kanal alle einzeln anschauen
die werden auch alle noch übersetzt in
ganz viele sprachen das ist auch eine
graffe technik die dahinter steckt und
ich selber jetzt im englischen schon
gesehen habe in anderen sprachen noch
nicht und ihr könnt sie auch bei uns auf
dem blog als auch sechs minuspunkte auch
alle einzeln anklicken und da wäre es
echt cool wenn ihr mir einfach euer
feedback schreibt und so gerade mit dem
hintergrund mit dem backstage video also
es war schon eine krasse zeit und ich
muss auch sagen ich hab die ganze zeit
über so kaum gesehen und ich habe auch
immer geguckt dass wir am set immer ganz
viel spaß haben und wir hatten auch ein
schönes catering muss ich sagen weil
eben nicht so viel zeit war zum selber
kochen und backen wobei ich während den
drehs oder auch nach dem dreh sven hier
eingeleuchtet wurde und es hat schon
teilweise mal so drei stunden gedauert
bis mal so das setup richtig
eingeleuchtet war und dann habe ich mich
hingestellt und buchteln gebacken oder
rahm kuchen oder schokokuchen und dann
gab es noch so am gleichen tag oder am
nächsten tag system ja da ist mir auch
immer wichtig dass sich jeder bei mir zu
hause wohl fühlt und das system an sich
eben gut zusammenpasst und das hat dann
schon gepasst also da muss ich sagen war
echte richtig coole zeit ja und nachdem
dann die sechs tage dreht hier vorbei
waren war für mich natürlich jetzt
erstmal so der dreh vorbei und für das
team von punch in also für die
produktionsfirma hat dann eigentlich die
eigentliche arbeit noch mal
die angefangen denn danach haben sie
noch mal ich hab sechs oder sieben
wochen lang die ganzen videos
geschnitten und auch 3d animationen
eingebaut also schon recht aufwendig
gewesen und ich finde das sieht man auch
in einem video sind echt schöne videos
geworden und auch sehr informativ muss
ich sagen und ich persönlich finde es
war für dieses jahr als für dieses
pandemie jahr nehme ich jetzt mal war es
echt ne tolle alternative vor allem weil
ich eben doch zum einen mit dem bosch
themen ganz intensiv arbeiten konnte und
wir uns echt super ausgetauscht haben
ich euch die neuheiten jetzt eben
vorstellen konnte aber ich muss sagen
ich hoffe natürlich fürs nächste jahr
dass die messe oder überhaupt alle
messen wieder stattfinden könnten
vielleicht unter anderen bedingungen ich
weiß es nicht ich kann das selber jetzt
nicht vorhersagen ich wünsche mir
natürlich dass ich nächstes jahr wieder
auf der messe stehen und für euch kochen
und backen kann was ich aber tatsächlich
diese sehr gut fand war zum einen dass
auch box als vier mal muss ich echt
sagen also gut ab dass so ein großer
konzern kann man schon sagen so spontan
war und so so schnell auch darauf
reagiert hat das wirklich die messe
trotzdem stattfinden konnte und ich
finde es haben wahrscheinlich nicht alle
gemacht und da ist bosch echten
innovatives team und sagt auch ok kommen
wir haben jetzt den mut wir machen das
jetzt einfach wir probieren es einfach
und da einfach nicht stehen bleiben und
sagen okay und sind jetzt die hände
gebunden wir machen einfach nichts draus
und das muss ich sagen finde ich ganz
gut ich konnte mich vor allem auf alle
technischen neuerungen vorbereiten und
mich auch wirklich darauf konzentrieren
so dass diese einzel videos entstehen
da muss ich nämlich sagen habe ich auf
den messen er weniger zeit oder weniger
die gelegenheit weil ich einfach wenn
ich auf der messe rung lauf wenn ich
natürlich oft auch angesprochen oder ich
unterhalte mich selber mit anderen und
dann ist natürlich die konzentration
nicht so da wie wenn du gezielt dann ein
video für ein produkt machst und das
fand ich jetzt ganz gut ich glaub ich
für mich fans ganz schön fürs nächste
jahr so eine kombination aus beidem zu
machen also schön die videoproduktionen
für die einzelnen geräte zu machen aber
daneben auch auf die messe zu gehen und
ihr könnt mir mal euer feedback geben
wie ihr das jetzt so findet wie wir die
ifa dieses jahr gelöst haben und ja
schreibt mir gerne euer feedback dazu
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
ich denke man hat einfach noch so viel
mehr backstage zeigen können ich habe
auch zum jj einfach ab und zu über wir
machen backstage aufnahmen aber ich war
einfach nonstop beim dreh und dann hab
ich den kopf dann auch gar nicht mehr
frei und oft waren josh und sarah und
auch die anderen vom team einfach nur
darum wie man kaffee zu bringen einfach
zeit mit ihr zu verbringen kürze
musikhören kurz ausrasten und karaoke
singen und eintrag so kurz wieder ja
irgendwie die welt normal werden lassen
oder ich war schon so war schon so
teilweise consell sieht noch durch du
schaffst es
weil man hätte natürlich den ganzen dreh
auch auf zwei wochen aufteilen können
dass es eben nicht so ganz zeitintensiv
war aber wir haben gesagt kaum eine
woche wir schaffen uns und wir uns
geschafft und ich muss sagen dafür haben
wir echt ganz cool gemacht also noch mal
ein ganz ganz großes dankeschön auch an
das komplette punch in themen gibt es
echt super gemacht und ich muss sagen
ich bin ja echt so ein mensch ich kann
also ich bin schon magic kann würde ich
sagen mit jedem also mit mir kann glaube
ich jeder arbeiten aber bei mir muss
halt echt immer die sympathie
überspringen also ich kann auch keinem
in die kamera lachenden ich irgendwie
nicht mag und dann also ich kann mich
halt nicht vorstellen dass es hat echt
so und wenn ich mich im team wohl fühle
dann fällt mir der dreh auch leicht und
wenn ich die person dahinter wenn die so
kalt zu mir sind da kann ich das dann
auch nicht und da muss ich sagen hat
echt super gepasst und deswegen habe ich
mich auch mega wohl gefühlt und ich
hoffe dass sich auch jeder bei uns wohl
gefühlt hat ja also soviel dazu und ich
hab dann immer so ganz ganz schlimme
abschieds schmerzen das ist echt weil
mir ich bin ich bin glaube ich immer zu
schnell nämlich der menschen voll in
mein herz auf und dann hab ich am ende
immer so und jetzt gebe alles
und dann war ich so alleine wieder mit
meinen kindern um dem buch aber es war
auch natürlich dann wird das sehr schön
ja jedenfalls wollte ich nur sagen dass
ich alles erwachte das war so die
aussage die ich treffen wollte okay der
jsc schon so ok also ich hoffe ihr
hattet spaß bei diesem backstage video
was ich noch sagen muss apropos
sympathie oben als wir irgendwie
hauswirtschaftsraum gedreht haben das
war praktisch also das 14 schon so
unsere privaten räumen schlafzimmer
kinderzimmer ankleide und keine ahnung
waschraum und da haben wir wirklich auch
so drei quadratmetern in diesem mini
wach schrauben haben wir einfach gefilmt
und es war so krass waren durch die
ganze lichter die waschmaschine
und alles rund um das ganze dann immer
aufzulockern über bella in ihrer
verkleidung kiste aber dann haben wir
uns alle verkleidet so als engel und als
marienkäfer uns ja also wir haben schon
ziemlich viel spaß beim drehen ja mal
eine lustige zeit also bis zum nächsten
mal
und wie gesagt die videos könnt ihr euch
auf einem baustopp kanal anschauen wer
auch mega cool wenn ihr euch an schaut
denn es steckt einfach so viel arbeit
dahinter und ich finde wenn ihr sie euch
mal anguckt und vielleicht darf schreibt
dazu das schon ganz schön denn ich muss
auch sagen das thema vielleicht echtes
noch als nachtrag das thema von bosch
dieses jahr war eben auch das thema
nachhaltigkeit und gesundheit und das
muss ich schon sagen wir haben zum
beispiel ihre kompletten geschirrspüler
alle geändert also wirklich die alpen
produktionen aufgehört zu produzieren
und wirklich alles ganz neu mit filtern
die man eben nicht mehr tauschen muss
wirklich ganz nachhaltig das wenig müll
entsteht umso weiter auch was das thema
küchen dunstabzugshaube oder backöfen
und so weiter kühlschränke angeht mehr
platz für mehr frisches für mehr obst
und gemüse also thema nachhaltigkeit und
gesundheit ist bosch wirklich super
wichtig und dafür nicht die technischen
innovationen echt mega also schauts euch
gerne an und hinterlasst uns euer
feedback